we talked it out and
I understand though you know what if
somebody when I was playing had had said
something about a player that played my
position and they didn't mention me I
would not have been happy either so I
I'm with it for Philip yeah
American may have been surprised by this
but we're not perfect folks we do make a
couple of sticks
what is happening here
in an old-fashioned stared out Kelly
Blitz
[Music]
that is unbelievable you want to
simulate what just happened
says I can't I can't do that I don't
have the fortitude to stare into your
eyes like that I don't think I've ever
seen that before
um between an official and a coach but
that's one way if you've got another
minute 29 who knows what we'll see next
here
and he got teed up for saying something
so I guess Brad figured he wouldn't say
anything
oh guard fouled
this is like the wild west back in the
day
oh my goodness
I love that they brought the space
closer together you know Kelly kind of
walked forward
never a dull moment in the Big Ten there
is never a dull moment